can we talk about your first time my
first time yeah in reference to what
we first roll you were ever offered
thing called Guinevere Jones was a kids
TV series and I played King Arthur and
it was basic I didn't have any lines I'm
ever been pretty nervous about it
actually it was the first person to ever
encourage you as an actor I think my
older brother he he had done an acting
course and suggested I do it and he was
sort of the first I guess inspiration
and and always said yeah guy would do
it's fun you loved it and that's how it
to them what's how I got into it do you
remember the first actor who inspired
you someone you saw on screen then
watching Brad Pitt a lot as a kid and
just loving his sort of charisma and
what everything he was doing the type of
films he was making and prior to even
knowing all to be an actor it was things
like neverending story and Princess
Bride and those kind of films that I
just love do you remember the first time
you thought about moving over here yeah
it was when I was finishing school and
talking to you know the careers advisor
at school about a cable what university
you're gonna sign up for were gonna do
and I think I'm gonna be an actor and
she's like well like a ball what's your
backup and I didn't really have one
there was nothing else I really wanted
to do and answer um you know put my head
down and wait for it what's the first
fairytale you remember loving as a child
my dad read to me and had very vivid
memories of it was The Hobbit the first
time they called action on the Huntsman
the first days always is always a little
sort of intimidating even worked with
this person before and actually was with
Jessie
Chastain who was you know incredibly
talented and intimidating for all the
respect for right reasons you know it
was like just not wanting to drop the
ball that's how it was feel do you know
when the first time you felt successful
was do you ever feel like yes I've made
it no I think it's an ongoing you know
challenge these things you feel proud of
and then this films where you'd feel
like I could have done that better you
know or I wish I'd done this I tried
that and do you remember the first time
you recognized in public after Star Trek
I got recognized as Chris Pine then I
was like it's not there like now you
you're Chris Pine you're in Star Trek
I'm like I was in it but or not that
character or often it's um you Liam no
say hi to him for me
you